in this video i'm going to be sharing
21 must-know facts tactics
and strategies for youtube shorts
the newest feature that is disrupting
youtube and the social media world and
we're really going to be covering
the details to discover if youtube
shorts is the best way to get views and
get discovered especially if you're just
starting from scratch
but also what are the cons of youtube
shorts can they hurt your analytics can
they hurt your channel can they annoy
your viewers and everything else you
need to know
when it comes to youtube shorts and
there's been some major
announcements um when it comes to these
now
uh if you've just hearing about youtube
shorts
building youtube shorts is a new way to
watch and create on
youtube um really youtube shorts is
a app feature that rivals tiktok and
instagram reels
and with the popularity of tiktok and
instagram reels and short form content
like that
you this is youtube's um response trying
to take that market share back
from instagram tick tock and other short
form places now
it just was announced that um
the shorts camera is available to
everyone in the us and is being rolled
out right now we'll talk about that with
these 21 different facts
but youtube short started in beta and so
it's been tested mainly in
india and it's been a massive impact in
india and then they've been rolling
out youtube shorts to different creators
at different levels and in a recent
earning
in a recent earnings report youtube
confirmed that shorts were getting
6.5 billion views a day
so that means that uh this could be a
very major way for you to get views on
your videos
um and to start building so let's cover
some facts and smash the like button if
you're fired up for this content
number one all of us creators have
access to the shorts camera that was
just
released and what that looks like is
uh when you go to the explore page you
will be able to or rather the post page
you will be able to start creating right
from your smart
phone pretty cool now number two you
actually don't need the shorts camera to
use
shorts so again the shorts camera if you
go to this little plus button
make sure you update your youtube app
and how you have the latest version of
your app
and you'll see this thing that says
create a
short you know from your phone you can
upload a video from your phone you can
go live
depending on how many subscribers you
have but from your phone you'll now see
in the us and at a lot of places around
the world the ability to create a short
and it might say the word beta next to
it that's what it says on my phone
then you'll be able to create a short
right from
your phone just like a tick tock or an
instagram reel it's got its unique
differences but it's sort of the same
idea now you didn't actually you don't
need the shorts
camera to create a short we've posted
about five shorts on our think media
channel so far
omar's been testing this and he's
actually done them all
just by editing in like adobe premiere
or whatever software
and shooting vertically on a phone or a
camera so this is a youtube short
being viewed on a desktop screenshot
and so you don't need a certain
subscriber number sean i want to be able
to do shorts but i don't have a thousand
subs yet you don't need that
i don't i need more watch time hours
it's not like monetization
you could start a brand new channel from
scratch and start posting shorts
so long as they're vertical in less than
60 seconds and
in this case though using the shorts
camera could give you some advantages
number three
shorts are vertical video might go
without saying
but shorts are not horizontal the key to
a short being a short
is that it's a vertical video phone
orientation
and it's less than 60 seconds and so
throughout the rest of this video i'm
going to be sharing
another 18 facts you need to know about
youtube shorts but i have a question for
you
have you posted a youtube short yet let
me know in the comments
are what do you think about youtube
shorts are you hesitant to use them have
you started watching any yet
are you do you even know what we're
talking about this is still a brand new
feature
and even though there's been some buzz
on youtube about this
you're super early if you're watching
this video this is this is still kind of
bleeding edge it's just rolling out this
week
on all phones here in the us in terms of
using the shorts camera
and so let me know your experience with
shorts and hit the like button
if you're getting uh value so far if
you're new to the show this is coffee
with kennel
and we're talking about youtube shorts
explained 21 things you need to know and
some new
updates uh my name is sean cannell my
passion is to help you build your
influence with youtube i've personally
grown a couple different youtube
channels to over 100 000 subscribers and
over a million
but i'm most proud of our students many
who've started from zero who've got that
silver play button or gone full-time so
if you're into
youtube uh information that will help
you get more views and more subscribers
as well as the best gear and cameras and
all that kind of stuff
smash the subscribe button and today's
video is brought to you by
ytimpact.com we actually have an
upcoming
challenge um it's five days and we're
going to be talking about
the best strategies for getting views
right now getting subscribers right now
some of the new changes on youtube and
ultimately how you can not just grow
your influence but also you can make a
difference in the lives of people and
really make an impact
around the world with your content and
so it's going to be fun it's free
yt impact.com is where all the re uh
resources are or link in the description
down below if you want to register for
that
it's starting soon but let's jump into
number four
shorts can be up to 60 seconds but they
don't have to be 60 seconds
in fact there's something that as you
start experimenting with shorts
you might want to keep them under 15
seconds quick um
you know punchy kind of that tick tock
kind of that instagram reels
you know different lengths on different
platforms uh so
you could max it out but try 15 seconds
try
35 try you know max 60 and so that is
what necessitates a short number five
you can use popular music
from the youtube library but only up to
15
seconds so this is pretty cool you can
use popular music
essentially copy written music but just
like tick tock or reals
youtube is integrating with the
publishing companies and the music
companies
so you could grab a popular song you
know
where do you get your peaches out in
georgia pull that in do your dance or
just put it on your
tutorial or your education content or
your um you know entertainment content
key as of right now you can only use 15
seconds of the song
so i was testing i uploaded a 30 second
video and the song just stopped at 15
seconds and then it was silent unless
there was audio on the video
so the music integration is gonna be
more
for 15 second really short form content
and um what's cool again is you can
create that
right from the shorts camera but
assuming you have the shorts camera you
can also upload
a pre-made video and still integrate
that with the popular music from the
youtube library
um captions are this is kind of a new
thing they announced are
auto generated or you can also self
supply the captions there's a way to
flip that on
and you can upload manual captions this
is not unlike a typical
youtube video and the viewer can toggle
between those two things number seven
how to get views so a couple different
ways to get views why
shorts sean how am i going to get views
on shorts so
what you can see here is there is a
traffic source on the right side of the
screen
of on desktop analytics saying that this
short
it was 58 seconds and omar made a video
on five simple youtube video ideas for
beginners
so suggested videos was the largest
traffic source in the last two days but
shorts
brought in 18.5 of
traffic and so the first way you can get
views on your shorts
is what's called the shorts shelf so if
you've updated your youtube app
you could log into your youtube app and
go to
either the homepage uh probably the
homepage or the subscriptions tab
and you'll see stories that's like a
story shelf
it's not youtube stories youtube shorts
is different
and you could scroll and eventually you
should see some youtube shorts now from
my testing as i'm seeing right here
i'm actually not seeing the short self
so what i'll do is i'll maybe go to
explore
subscriptions maybe i'll crash the app
and i'll reopen the app and eventually
that short
shelf will show up so basically the way
you know if you're going to see
if you see it or not there you go so it
says shorts
beta and i know this would be like weird
depth of field but i can
you know you can scroll between and this
is a short shelf
on the home page of um
my smartphone and once i click in one of
those i can go down a rabbit trail of
shorts being recommended to me
the first couple are maybe from channels
i've subscribed to
um and then it'll lead me to
channels i have not subscribed to so
this is the dream of shorts right
that you could start getting discovered
and getting traffic from the shorts
shelf and so that's just one way of
getting
views here's another short it was 44
seconds
how to shoot better video on your phone
26.3
of the traffic on this video meaning the
last two days almost 600 views
so that means 50 views of this video in
the last two days
came from the shorts shelf or shorts
players or shorts traffic right
so now they may already know think media
but again that is the chance to meet 50
new people you've never met
before super powerful number eight how
to get views the shorts
tab now this was just announced they
have said
that shorts will actually replace the
explore tab on the home screen
and so um it sounds like and seems like
youtube's going to be leaning super
heavy
into the explore tab i've also seen up
top i don't know if you've noticed these
little bubbles there's little bubbles at
the top
that allows me to filter my content i
can filter right now
i can click confidence grant cardone
sales podcasts motivation
so it's studying my viewing behavior and
it's letting me like select
categorically what's being shown to me
on the home page
i've seen shorts show up there and down
at the bottom of the screen they'll be
home
possibly shorts then the ability to
create content and then
uh the subscriptions and then your
library etc so it'll be
actually the shorts tab should be and
this is what they said on the creator
insider channel
somehow integrated into the bottom there
maybe replacing explorer
we'll have to see or maybe it'll be
inside of explore i don't see it right
there
again update your youtube app and start
playing around to discover some youtube
shorts
now number nine you can get views on
youtube shorts
from all the traditional traffic sources
so you can get views on the homepage
somebody could search and find a short
that you can get in the subscription
feed
so notice this particular video
that we posted on think media 44 second
long short
it has 26 percent traffic from shorts
but 23
traffic from channel page pages 19
traffic from browse features so that's
like the home page right
14 from suggested videos because a short
is uploaded
at this time to your main channel or
whatever youtube channel
it can still be viewed on desktop it
could still be recommended on the
homepage even as a short
of course shorts lend themselves more
towards mobile but we're getting a lot
of traffic
from desktop and all of the traditional
youtube
traffic sources number 10 you can watch
shorts on desktop and smart tvs
um so kind of just said that but
a lot of people the majority because
think media is established and has
subscribers are actually watching shorts
just on desktop you know black on the
side of it
you can also watch shorts on smart tvs
but every night pretty much every night
i watch youtube on my smart tv with my
wife and my son
sean bradley and we are flipping around
we almost we really never see shorts
recommended like
they don't really show up on the smart
tv however if you're subscribed to a
channel
you can find it watch it and then sure
enough it'll be vertical on your tv
tony ariola and i on the think media
team were debating about this he was
like man
you know i hate vertical on a smart tv
or whatever
you know it doesn't feel like the right
experience and i said i actually don't
even really notice i mean obviously you
notice
but i think about a channel like daily
dose of the internet and they mix
together
full screen content they mix together
viral content from like a tik-tok
and to me it kind of all works together
and i've noticed we haven't seen a lot
of negative comments
from people watching shorts on desktop
on our think media channel or any
if the content's good and if it serves
the viewer then you can almost watch it
you know anywhere but of course shorts
are intended for mobile
consumption uh number 11 the only
shorts views that will be monetized are
desktop
views at this time now youtube's been
saying this is a new
feature this is a huge emphasis
i believe it could be the next greatest
revolution on youtube right
and really a new thing to lean into or
maybe it just
kind of levels out and it's just a
segment of youtube kind of like snapchat
didn't die and there's like a segment of
people who knows we'll see where it goes
so they're going to be exploring
monetizing shorts
potentially directly but at this point
it's only if the desktop views that are
monetized
so for example this short 58 seconds
long
has gotten 19 000 views now here's
what's cool it grew the channel 31
subscribers
so that's that's growth and they can
watch other videos not just shorts now
that they're a subscriber right
and it's made eight dollars and sixty
three cents so that is
not super impressive because
the only views that are a monetized are
going to be
the uh you know desktop views and b the
video show so
short it maybe is not going to make a
ton of money now here's one
44 seconds the uh playback cpm and think
media here
13 bucks pretty good the rpm oh my gosh
is three dollars meaning we keep about
four bucks youtube's keeping 10 in this
case
ouch youtube uh and
but you know it brought in what point is
this our
most profitable videos on think media
are actually our longest videos mainly
probably because there's multiple ad
spots so we can go to revenue
and look at our top videos our top
three videos are like 45 minutes or
longer that earn money
and then one of our other videos
probably because of high volume and that
would be because of
multiple ad spots again so this video
has earned
obviously a lot of views twenty thousand
dollars
and um when you go to monetization
and you go to manage mid roles you know
one two three ads play during this ads
can play before and after so it's
potentially more ads being seen
but i've noticed that sometimes revenue
goes up when content is
longer so the punch line is really just
thinking about the fact that
um from a direct youtube adsense
monetization standpoint
shorts is is really not the way to go
but it doesn't mean you shouldn't use
them
number 12 add
shorts in the title or description
adding uh
hashtag shorts in the title or the
description might increase your views
now uh this is also kind of
maybe outdated information because
youtube has been rolling out
in beta youtube shorts has been testing
and like does the algorithm does the
platform see it hey make sure to add
hashtag shorts to the title
hey make sure to add hashtag shorts in
the description and
this is maybe subjective information
here's what i've learned
youtube will know that your video is a
short if you do not add the hashtag
and the way you know that is on mobile
if you look at the lower right hand
corner of the video it actually doesn't
show you the time it shows you the
shorts logo
all you have to do is upload a video
that's vertical in less than 60 seconds
and it seems to me at this point youtube
knows it's a short however
many different experts or whoever have
said that if you add hashtag shorts to
the title or description
it might help it reach the short shelf
or being recommended in shorts
sooner we have not been adding it to the
title just to keep the title
cleaner we add hashtags to the
description in this case we said hashtag
think media hashtag omar
altacory and hashtag shorts so shorts is
shows up as those three hashtags above
the title
and whether it's there or not we've seen
traffic from the short
shelf so that's up to you to test you
know
best practice could be uh putting in the
title if you want putting in it in the
description so it shows up as a hashtag
if you want or not using it at all you
can see how we're doing it there
uh by just putting it in the description
as a clickable hashtag
that is the shorts logo on screen if
you're listening to this on audio
um it's this little kind of s
version of the red youtube background
with the play button
and you'll see this little icon on the
lower right hand corner
of your mobile phone on a shorts video
and if you scroll through your
subscription feed and some of the people
you're following are uploading shorts
you should see that little logo number
13 you can post shorts
on your current youtube channel or a new
channel huge
question we get all the time sean
should i post shorts on my main channel
should i start a second channel a couple
rapid fire answers
number one managing two channels is very
difficult so starting a second channel
might be something you want to avoid if
time is scarce
number two if short form content would
really
violate your viewer and the promise
you've made to your viewer
which may just be an assumption you're
making but if that is the case
yes you could potentially shift your
content to a shorts only channel
another thing you can consider is that
if you have a big library of
instagram reels or tick tocks you know
you can download your tick tocks without
the tick tock logo
by going in and it allows you to access
your data and i think you can download
them all at once
that's best practice by the way reels
hates when they see the
tick tock logo there and they'll reduce
your search your your reach
so if you maybe have some other less
than 60 second content now maybe if
music is embedded you know you could run
into all kinds of issues and you may
want to resync
the the song from the youtube library
you can figure all that out
punchline is you could experiment with
posting shorts on your current channel
where you're posting
horizontal video typical youtube video
or you could start a new channel and
people are doing both
for us at think media we've posted five
or six shorts now on our main channel
we are never posting two shorts uh in a
row
and our goals eventually we post five
videos a week on think media right now
our goals eventually be at seven days a
week
and do two shorts a week we've had times
to put some ease on our schedule as
we're shifting things around
done like three normal videos and two
shorts and
from our standpoint and our share some
personal insights and tips
towards the end of this video is
is uh it's been great like it really has
a lot more to do with the content
and if it adds value to the viewer than
it does with how long it is or
necessarily whether it's vertical or not
eventually we want to start a clips
channel where it wouldn't just be shorts
but it may be
just like clips from other videos or
clips from our podcast the think media
podcast
like eventually we want to do that but
hear me
we're a team of creators at think media
and we don't even
at this point feel like we have the
bandwidth to start a second channel now
mind you we're posting a ton of videos
on our main channel but you get you get
my
energy here i would recommend that you
experiment with posting shorts on your
main channel
and test it see the vibe before leaning
in like i'm just starting a new channel
i'm starting a whole new thing
you know what i mean like that
potentially could take your distraction
from the main thing but of course
up to you number 14 shorts will affect
your analytics but should not hurt your
channel the other objection is
oh my gosh my views are going or my
average view duration's going down
across my channel
like uh one of the good channels to
check out that does shortswell is legal
eagle
not only does he have long-form videos
but he's posting about five shorts a
week
and he said his average view duration on
his whole channel has gone down
massively
because he posts so many shorts they're
short and so
the avd the average viewership on the
whole channel has been pulled down
but then he said but it didn't hurt the
channel it just changed the numbers
around
youtube's judging yes your whole channel
on really two things
the individual performance of a video
like a video will succeed or fail on its
own merits
and also the total watch time minutes so
the average view duration has gone down
because he still posts the same number
of long form videos but also
he posts um you know short it's like
three to five shorts a week
but the total watch time minutes on his
channel has skyrocket
rocketed so from youtube standpoint they
might be like well people aren't what
you know
net net youtube is getting more time on
platform from the viewership
of course you always have to be
analyzing and testing things but that's
something to be aware of people are
afraid that it'll affect their macro
channel analytics
um which it certainly would if you
posted a ton of shorts but that doesn't
necessarily mean that it'll hurt your
channel number 15
you can add end cards to your
shorts and so here's an example of
uh one of the shorts on the thick media
channel and
at the end it actually this was about
the best way to potentially invest if
you wanted to build a battle station or
invested some gear
to use uh the stimulus check to
you know start a business start creating
something that will make you money you
know start a youtube channel
or like you know upgrade your current
studio and the short was
short so the call to action was like if
you want more
details on this or a full breakdown of
some of the best gear we recommend
click or tap the screen to check out
that full video so
you can use shorts to potentially point
to your other videos and so
um uh
next 16. you can ask viewers to like and
subscribe
and share and so if you're thinking
about creating a short
um realize what is happening on the
shorts player people can hit the like
button
they can hit the dislike button they can
leave a comment they can click the share
button
they can see what song is playing in the
lower right hand corner
um they can click the subscribe button
they can click on your channel and go to
your channel
so there's a whole bunch now if you
understand how the navigation of youtube
shorts
works then it can influence your content
and potentially your call to action for
example
lately we've been letting our shorts
just kind of survive on their own merits
hopefully recommend one of our videos
next or another short next
think about the viewer mindset the
viewer mindset might be
that they are um
wanting to continue to watch a bunch of
short form content so they may not want
to leave
and they're just kind of going through
these quick hits dopamine hits of like
cool dancing oh cool tip oh wow that's a
cool way to use the camera what a cool
camera hack
oh my gosh look at that cute puppy wow
those ducks are riding on that turtle
you know like all kinds of different
things and going in that mode but if you
want to potentially direct attention or
get something going you know
hit like if you got value and you know
and seeing the next one i would never
probably tell you don't have enough time
to tell people to do all the things and
you should never
really just go down the list like hey so
if you're new here hit like
leave a comment hit the share button
hits i mean that could be really
annoying there's too much stuff so think
about
maybe like one call to action when it
comes to your short and how
and think about the viewer journey you
know and where they're going to go next
and how this integrates with your
content number 17
and if you would hit the like button if
you're getting value out of this video
uh grabbing attention quickly is
critical for shorts
maybe goes without saying if you haven't
listened to our episode on the think
media podcast with brendan kane
the author of hook point hooks are
everything in social media
grabbing attention up front the first
few seconds and on youtube
we like to say a hook is the first 15 to
over
a minute like you might spend the
beginning of the video
kind of like grabbing attention you know
painting a picture of what's coming up
letting people know what's coming up
grabbing attention but
on shorts it's even shorter you know
like have you ever seen uh when there's
youtube ads of a movie trailer and the
movie trailer
is like a minute but there's a
five-second trailer
for the movie trailer have you noticed
that like it's like boom because
especially it's like you can skip it on
youtube
and it's like and you're like what the
heck
and then they're trying to hook you for
a hook
like it's like you know real meta in
terms of how much attention we're trying
to grab and how quickly
just something to think about shorts
boom the short from the short shelf is
in front of them
what do they see what do they hear it
might be less about what they hear
i mean you're assuming on the youtube
app they're more prone to have audio on
but just grabbing attention is going to
be super critical for shorts
thinking about that opening scene
definitely don't start
with like some logo or some boring intro
or some five seconds uh you know
seconds matter like the first second of
the short
the short might only be seven seconds
you know consider
vine strategy like the telling stories
in very
short amounts of time so number 17 is
grabbing attention quickly
for shorts number 18 shorts could be a
great way for you to get discovered on
youtube
i mentioned that youtube last numbers
were that
shorts is getting 6.5 billion views
daily
people are watching shorts 6.5 billion
views a day globally that's over 200
billion views a month
so if you're struggling to get views if
you've been struggling to get traction
if you're trying to find your thing and
trying to find a way to break through on
youtube and get described discovered by
people that
that don't know you shorts could be a
really
great uh tool or resource to try that if
it aligns with your content
always something to experiment with um
and then at the same time
you know maybe you're already
established maybe things are already
uh happening shorts you don't want it to
be just a gimmick for you
and what i mean is you know on think
media we're trying to be very sensitive
to what's the perfect
short that still honors the promise
we've made on the channel and honors the
viewer honors
the community and we've noticed that if
the video is valuable
and short and vertical people love it um
and if it doesn't if it's not a
gimmick gimmicky or off brand so this
isn't necessarily just a way to hack
views for views sake but if you can find
a way to align it
with your current content or just
experiment it could be a really
good way to get views and remember at
the end of the day people are more
important than algorithms
algorithms is not even what it's about
so yes shorts can hack the algorithm
right now
but there's always people on the other
side what is that people thinking
if you also reach a ton of people and
get millions of views but from the wrong
audience
that could lead to maybe a new thing for
you but it might what good is it to get
three million people seeing your content
that has nothing to do with
your vision your business model your
values the purpose of your youtube
channel if you want to pivot you're
playing cool
but sometimes it's not just about again
numbers
if you will vanity metrics it's more
about impact it's more about the people
you serve
so something to consider in your shorts
strategy number 19
you can repurpose your youtube shorts to
tick tock and ig reels
so we're trying to continue to expand
here at think media
again or a team of content creators um
over the years i think to really be
effective on social media
and to live your life you're in one of
two seasons you're either in the
sacrifice season
where you're really just hustling and i
know that's where a lot of our community
is
maybe full-time job and kids and you're
trying to work 10 or 20 hours a week
to build your youtube channel and you
know like when
when that's the case by the way it'd be
very difficult to be great at tick tock
great at ig reels great at youtube great
at youtube shorts
going live on linkedin like if you try
to do everything especially when time is
limited
um you'll probably spread yourself too
thin i think it's important to be
really focused on the most effective
thing the best use of your time
your time the essential ingredients
necessary to you getting to the next
stage which in my opinion
would be making enough money so you can
work less hours at work or go full time
or maybe hiring someone to help so for
us
in terms of trying to dominate all the
social platforms for me that's been
having a team
support and help me and we're not even
on tick tock i mean i'm on tick tock but
i post like two
and and we're not really on uh we
haven't done a ton of ig reels
our macro goal just so you can get an
insider look at what we're doing at
think media
is actually to think shorts first and
then to use shorts and have a trickle
down from shorts
to tic toc and ig reels and not just in
a robot
robotic fashion but sometimes think
would this piece of content work good on
all three platforms
especially if we integrate music we
could potentially integrate it on all
three platforms
natively selecting the song because
that'd be the only way to really get the
music right
on each platform and therefore creating
the short
uploading it from the shorts camera on
my smartphone first to youtube
you know selecting i got my peaches out
in georgia
you know and then going over to reels
and maybe doing the same thing and then
tick tock
and kind of having like just a strategic
planning of where does each piece of
content go
again you could think tick tock tick
tock first or ig reels first
but we're kind of a youtube first
company anyways youtube is the only
platform where your content lasts
forever it's a search engine all these
other things
so that's the way we're going to do it
i'd love to hear how you're going to do
it in the comments
and what your vision would be of trying
to dominate these short form platforms
or or kind of be multiple places but
being efficient with your time
number 20 a short could be a good way to
introduce a full video you know we
mentioned that
uh for example we're gonna do like a
video coming up soon called
um best lenses for the canon m50
and there's actually or like all the
lenses like top 10 lenses because
there's not
a ton of lenses for the canon m50 but
we'll go through like all of them
so okay if that's the full length video
then
the short could be the top three lenses
for the canon m50
it could add value in and of itself but
then it also could
uh link to and like and if you want to
see all 10 of the
of the best lenses for the canon m50
click or tap the screen and use an end
card now from our testing
sometimes the end cards don't show up
and there could be bugs in the system
bugs in the matrix
they're probably always working those
out on youtube but it is a new
feature and it is evolving so how things
flow and end cards that you know all
could change
but it could be a way to introduce a
full video which also gives you the
opportunity if i'm sitting down to make
10 best lenses for the canon m50 after
i'm done with that or while i'm doing it
i could also make
a short of three
of you know the three best lenses for
the canon m50 and kind of have a one-two
punch of a long form in a short form
video
think about how that could work for you
and i've seen some people that actually
do previews of a video they do a short
that's like a preview it's kind of like
a commercial
i'm not the biggest fan of that because
i always want an individual upload
to add value to the viewer in and of
itself and not just be a commercial for
something else
as much as possible but you know you do
you and that's just a thought that
you could intervi intro yeah
you know integrate shorts with
pointing to full videos and maybe vice
versa and playlists and cross-promoting
we call that circular video viralocity
here at think media where you're kind of
always thinking about how you can
strategically while adding value
cross-promote your content from
playlists to videos
to the part one two three to this
to that to other things constantly kind
of cross-promoting
again in a way that always adds value to
the viewer and number 21
shorts will continue to evolve and that
maybe goes without saying
they're at a huge place of maturity
right now
because uh they're the cameras now
rolled out to the full u.s
you can see youtube is fully behind
shorts it's gonna be a thing for sure
it already is a thing i would some
advice
is also that if you feel like you're
late you're definitely not late you're
super early
um you know for me i started really
hearing about shorts
in clubhouse rooms like at the beginning
of this year
like months ago and i also felt anxiety
like oh my gosh i gotta do another thing
there's a whole nother thing to do i
gotta but i didn't let that
you know derail me mind you the season
of life i'm in father
new new son realizing that man sometimes
i'm not gonna
you know just grind into late night
evenings i'm gonna spend time with
family it's the season i'm in
i remember when it was just my wife and
i and there maybe was a new opportunity
like this
i would just grind my face off to jump
on it quick you got to determine what
season of life you're in
but as far as you reacting to this my
point is this
we started game planning at think media
but it took us like a couple months to
like
ramp up to this because we kept our
current content schedule going we didn't
like
anxiety or paranoia or like am i going
to be too late and i think
that that's a good place to be i mean
social media the internet can do that to
you do you ever feel that way i'm
missing out
i'm missing out on the coolest shiny
object i'm missing out oh there's all
this stuff i need to be everywhere
no you don't like you got to make you
know i think it's worth it to think
things through
and here's my point if you adopt shorts
in the next one to three months three
months from now it's going to be new
if you adopted in 2021 it's going to be
new in 2021
um and so mark zuckerberg said
move fast and break things unless you're
breaking stuff you're not moving fast
enough
if you're hesitant i love that quote in
fact i have it on my wall
uh on a startup vitamins poster move
fast and break things
posting one short on your channel is not
gonna like ruin your whole world you
know what i mean it's not your
subscribers aren't gonna like hate you
but you gotta listen and always listen
to their feedback and think about the
value
so move fast test it try it post
three post one or two try it you know
mess around with it if you're not
breaking something you're not moving
fast enough
but then i would say this be a fast
mover
uh but not a first mover one of the
other reasons why
we've been waiting is some people are
saying is shorts gonna have its own
like player on the home page is it gonna
be uploaded different is there going to
be different features to it
some people are like should i turn
notifications on or not so that when i
release a short it doesn't
know my annoying my desktop viewers so
you can experiment now and you're going
to be an
early adopter which is great there could
be a lot of opportunity for you right
now
but there's also you don't want to wait
too long but be a fast mover not
necessarily a first mover i feel like
that's kind of where we are right now
we're kind of like wading our toes into
the water being
smart with it um you know my frantic
energy was like we better do this in
february you know like right when i
heard about it but it was like okay
let's keep reading the news studying it
studying how it works in different
niches and i've seen some people who've
posted a bunch of shorts
they've kind of worked and i'm like but
what really is it led to
i mean they sort of got on the short
shelf like how's it uh
connect to your bigger strategy so i
think experiment a little with shorts
just kind of some personal advice don't
stress out like posting one or two or
three is gonna destroy your channel
there's no way it would do that like it
might you might go huh you could read
the comments get some feedback
it might lead to a whole new opportunity
and a whole content pivot for you
and and then continue to stay subscribed
here and get information
because no doubt about it this will
evolve and we will be committed to
always bring you the best information
here at the think brand uh so that you
can always get more views build your
influence
and make a bigger impact with the
content that you're creating
and that reminds me uh to of the
question of the day
i want to hear your story about shorts
do you think they're legit
do you think they've hurt your channel
have you got negative or positive
feedback if you've posted some in the
comments
have you posted one yet is the shorts
camera did you update your app do you
see the shorts camera
down below maybe if you're outside of
the us do you have the shorts camera
what questions do you still have
about shorts um and what is your overall
feeling
of all these platforms trying to be all
these platforms
what do i mean everybody's trying to
have every feature youtube's got stories
youtube's got shorts youtube's got long
form youtube's got
live video youtube's got a community tab
that's supposed to be like a wall
of a you know what i mean like youtube's
adding more stuff
and so sometimes does it feel like a
little noisy is it kind of overwhelming
i would love to hear from you and those
were just some of my thoughts and as a
reminder i'm so pumped because
today's video is brought to you by the
youtube impact challenge
we've never done this challenge before
five days
seven sessions um we're going to be
talking about how you can start and grow
a high impact and high profit youtube
channel in 2021
but really from the energy of how to
make a difference in the lives of people
so if you go to ytimpack.com
or click or uh you know tap the link in
the description down below
that'll take you to a place where you
can register we've noticed
that youtube especially during the
pandemic
you know people are learning new skills
people during time when there's a mental
health crisis
and we need an escape and entertainment
um
youtube viewership has gone up hopefully
this channel has taught you things and
we get so many stories of people that
are making money or that have quit their
job or that have hit their first 1 000
subscribers
you know we're seeing people learn how
to eat healthy get in shape we're seeing
people learn how to
recover after divorce we're seeing
people you know youtube really has the
chance
to impact people's lives and we have the
chance with youtube
to not just make a significant living
and build a life and business on our own
terms
you know signal fire revealed that being
a creator is the fastest growing small
business type
if your friends your family your aunt
your uncle's like why don't you get a
real job
you can say uh this is a real job you
know like i don't know if you
realize this is the fastest growing
small business type
and it's not just something though that
you can make a living with but you also
really can truly make a difference in
the lives of people i think about nicole
she's helping new moms and as a new dad
we're figuring out tummy time and we're
trying to figure out
you know feeding schedules and we're
trying to figure out what foods
you know sean bradley my seven month old
can eat right
you know i think about uh i just was on
instagram live with somebody who
said there's a revolution in armenia and
she hit 10 000 subs
she's working full-time on on youtube
with a beauty channel and she's helping
other
uh armenians in her in her community uh
get on youtube and like
share their voice and she's speaking
native language on that channel
i think about uh different channels that
are doing so many things whether it's
mpc beats or whether it's helping dads
or whether it's
talking about politics or whether it's
helping people with their boat
or helping people with marketing or grow
their business
you can make a real impact and i know
you know that but that's the heart and
energy
behind the youtube impact challenge and
we're gonna take
five days to build momentum so if you're
done dabbling and you're ready to start
dominating youtube
you're gonna love this ytmpack.com link
in the description down below
to uh check all of that out
and we're gonna jump into some q a but
hey this is the coffee with kennel
show what are you sipping on let me know
in the comments down below
uh i uh i'm drinking mud water
yeah m-u-d-w-t-r mud water
i was re-targeted pixel [ __ ] by all
their ads and i was like i better buy
it's like a bio
it tastes awful probably not a good
endorsement for them but it's really
healthy for you shout out to the super
chat
uh nick pixel tv been telling uh
my audience very similar advice for
months appreciate you
many blessings um let me know what
you're sipping on
and we're going to be answering some
questions tony ariola has been helping
me on the back end so i got a
bunch of shorts questions that i'm gonna
hit rapid fire and so we're gonna uh
kick the tires and light the fires but
we got
we got some water george good to see you
we got protein shakes up in here
uh green smoothie my favorite victoria
thanks for being here
awesome uh and let's see
milo coffee that sounds amazing excuse
me
and water with lemon that's a good one
detox
clean awesome okay let's jump into some
uh questions here
i'm gonna see if tony can get these
earlier ones but life with marin asks
how could shorts fit into a content
strategy
so i touched on that a little bit um you
know again
at think media what we're thinking about
is this
are we serving the viewer with the
original promise we made on the channel
maybe that's the bigger picture you
should answer okay
which is this who is your channel for
and what problem does it solve or what
promise are you making to them
so the think brand is for
purpose-driven people that want to build
their influence
and income with youtube so
we teach online video and cameras and
all of that youtube is sort of the tip
of the platinum our main platform
and therefore what problem does it solve
i don't know what camera to buy i don't
know how to set up stream yard which is
what we're using
and how we go live i don't know how to
go live i don't know how to use you you
know like a million questions
or what promise does it make the promise
is if you
subscribe to this channel you're going
to get more views if you implement the
information
you're going to get subscribers you're
going to get clarity on your channel
you're going to figure out how to boost
your cpm get more money
multiple different ways to monetize like
we are
player coaches the team at think media
in the trenches getting results on
multiple channels
and we're going to pass that information
along to you to help you reach your
goals
i think that having a clear vision of
who you're trying to reach and then what
problem you solve or what promise
helping
what what are the problems and ambitions
of your audience
and how are you helping them reach those
i don't think the content format matters
by the way if you're really building a
strong brand across multiple platforms
that should be what people get from you
everywhere so whether you follow me on
instagram
at sean cannell you can see it in the
corner of the screen if you want to
connect over there
you're going to see ig tvs reels profile
posts
my stories during the day definitely
about 30
personality but about 70 percent youtube
tips
camera tips the same promise and whether
it's a 15 second story
a 60-second short a one-hour livestream
a five-day youtube impact challenge like
it's it's leading people to or serving
around that one big idea i think if
just as some general branding advice and
if you want to really stand out online
if you are seven different people on
seven different platforms with seven
different
problems and seven different pain points
if you try and reach everybody with all
this different messaging
it's maybe why you're not growing and
why you're not breaking through the
noise
so it's really about uh
how do i you know clarify
my content strategy and then determine
what are the best
formats platforms uh you know
formats like long form or short form
content that could fulfill on that
promise and i think that's why
as we're dialing in our strategy desktop
viewers of shorts
are loving it because by the way if it's
creativity works best in constraints
it actually forces you if you make a
good short to deliver value in a short
amount of time
it forces you to trim the fluff in fact
i encourage you to experiment with
shorts
just to sharpen the axe
if you will of your content creation
abilities
you only have 60 seconds so you have to
get your message across
in a much shorter time which will help
you become a better content creator
a better communicator and even if you
don't get tons of results from shorts
today
it'll be training you and giving you
skills for potentially
future short form content because you're
learning how to communicate
in a condensed manner wendy asks as a
freelance writer
who writes about tech health and
wellness how do i can create an umbrella
topic
for my channel so to me
if that's all supposed to be under one
umbrella i mean tech seems way different
than health and wellness
unless it's tech health and wellness of
course there's there's kind of
you know when we go to ces here in las
vegas there's an entire
three floors you know 20 000 square feet
each
of health trackers
tech for health wellness products for
health so that becomes incredibly
uh clear i think about dad verb he's one
of our video ranking academy students
he covers a lot of different baby
products but he mainly covers tech
because there's so many
four babies like there's so many
different and for kids
it could be like you know the little
thing we put on our kid's toe
the alley so like we know if if you stop
breathing at night or something that's
new tech
it didn't even really work we took it
back so super expensive but hey
you know um you could just get a piece
of plastic
or like a lot of us as parents you maybe
just change your kid on like a wooden
table that's burly
or you get a really nice electronic
scale weight music playing you know for
486 dollars at bye bye baby
for a changing table dude it just needs
to be a piece of plastic in fact you
don't even need a piece of plastic
you just need a raw rough
sandpapered up like 9 grit i don't know
if i said my grit right you get the idea
so to me i would say that
you want kind of one cohesive big idea
and if it was like
this is the best camera for youtube and
then it was like here's five tips for
how you can sleep better at night like
that's that's like some difference
but if it's all like health and wellness
and there's tech under health and
wellness
that's the cohesive brand in my mind don
is there a way to organize all of your
shorts in one place
on our youtube page you can put them all
in a playlist and
don i believe that over time
well i'm basically certain but we'll
have to see how this evolves
that youtube will um
like maybe create a short shelf
on your channel create a shorts tab on
your channel
that's all speculative right now but
there will be tons of changes over the
years with this
richard does my canon m50 mark ii and
vertical
mode work for shorts absolutely there's
some good videos that are coming out
uh very soon on think media omar's
training on how to make a short
with your smartphone or with you know a
nicer camera
and the key is again you don't
necessarily need the shorts camera that
means you're creating it in app
you could just start filming you could
shoot you know one clip vertical one
another clip vertical you could use
imovie
or lumafusion or some other app and just
edit together a vertical video
and then you can just upload it
like from the normal upload feature from
your phone
not necessarily the shorts camera or
from a desktop
and it'll be a short if it's vertical in
under 60 seconds
if you want we've gotten the reputation
omar has gotten the reputation of being
the crispiest shorts
uh you know on the internet because
they're made with
uh you know sony uh cameras and
uh they're all time crit they might be
shot in 4k some of them
and obviously shorts i don't think are
4k although actually i do probably think
it wouldn't actually whatever it
wouldn't be like 4k or whatever but i
digress
let's just check out a little short here
uh from
drippy crispy hashtag omar al takori
and so this
is a short not created with a phone but
edited together on like
adobe premiere or whatever and so um
there is uh this is again made
post-produced in editing software and
then just uploaded
as a short and so however you do it
definitely using
your m50 mark ii um
would be great but using a smartphone is
great as well and there's something
about also maybe
the look and feel of a smartphone i mean
these are doing great
but i think the expectation of tick tock
and reels is that
um it's kind you know tick tock reels
youtube shorts
is kind of smartphone quality or
smartphone vibes
so don't let tech be a limitation to you
and think you need a nice camera but
richard absolutely can use a nice camera
cass
you may be answering this but how should
you integrate shorts into your upload
schedule
so for us the goal was
and i really don't recommend this i want
you to understand nolan's making videos
omar's making videos sean is making
videos recently jordan
made videos heather makes videos tony
drops a video every here and there so
that's like that's like six people
and we're uploading five videos a week
we have kyle helping edit
think media has grown now if you don't
know my story oh they're they're a big
corporation now they're
dude i'm a freaking small town kid
college dropout
i started shooting videos in my bedroom
like
stop drinking the haterade like freak
you know
like it's cool that we've blown up and
grown as a fam
but like you can do this at any level
like oh he's got a video editor and
people helping him
i didn't used to and that energy you can
take that wherever you want to take it
and plan it where the sun don't okay
listen
like there's just different seasons and
i've done literally at all
just like you you're the camera guy
you're the editor you're the scripter
you're planning it out etc
the reason i share all that is because
us sustaining our content schedule
of five videos a week on think media two
videos a week on the think media podcast
in a video podcast
as well as bonus uploads and adding two
shorts
teamwork makes the dream work man so in
terms of your schedule
cass you may want to look at like
uh you know maybe you upload one video a
week two videos a week and you can carve
out the ability to add a short to your
schedule
going in addition to the one or two a
week you upload now
um that you may be pulling off by
yourself legal eagle
i think has one person helping him and
he shoots
he batch produces three to five shorts
last time i talked to him on clubhouse
on like sunday night and then he hands
those off to an editor
they're edited very basic but they are
crispy as well
and like shot with a more pro camera and
so
that one editor can handle the long form
editing and the other editing another
example we didn't really talk about
thumbnails of shorts
um he just uploads these basic
thumbnails because the thumbnails are
only going to be seen on desktop
is important to know right they're not
seen at all on the actual shorts player
and so
here's an example of his short shot
crispy they add some photos they add
some
he just delivers some information in 60
seconds sometimes he makes them two
parts so he basically keeps it under two
minutes
the editor is doing all of this for him
right
and uh he's uploading multiple we good
channel to study regarding shorts
and he's got his longer form content as
well and
let's go to most popular to see if any
of these shorts like really popped yet
we got a couple
multi-million viewed videos um we go
down here 1.3 million
uh lawyer reacts to lectern writer's
lawyer
1.3 million views three months so some
shorts can really break out and get that
short's recommendation or whatever he
also gets a lot of traffic from the fact
he has 1.8 million subscribers so that's
important to know
and so that's a good channel to look at
in terms of maybe short strategy and
and what he's doing in regards to shorts
um
but if you were going to integrate
shorts into your upload schedule yeah i
might try to do one a week
and he shoots three to five so you could
batch produce your shorts he's also
he reacts he thinks about what are the
latest news stories that i should react
to in my niche as a lawyer right
and he gets those in the can so yeah i'd
maybe i'd maybe start trying to do
one a week and what we'll eventually do
cass is even though we want to go five a
week and we were thinking about like two
on the weekends
two shorts like and now start going
seven days a week at think media
i i think we'll intersperse them like
it doesn't even matter in my opinion too
much which day is which
it's just seven total and probably not
two shorts in a row
but like i don't know kind of get a
general idea and then just go for it and
and always you know what gets measured
gets improved and so
review things um as you go you know our
video ranking academy framework
right the final r is
review and at some point you go through
the entire process
of creating videos that get views right
and then you go okay let me see what the
what can i learn or rather the six
hours review and then the seventh r is
repeat but now with more wisdom
informed based on your past data what
gets measured
gets improved so number six you're
reviewing your analytics and your data
and you're getting those insights you're
saying okay let me adjust that strategy
by the way if like three months from now
we go i don't know if we even need to
post shorts
we would stop if we're like we should go
four shorts and three full length you
know
always just kind of evolving as we go
because we're measuring and seeing
what's working and what data we could
get
mindstormer i don't want to have my uh
subs not coming back
for long-term content should i advertise
my long-form content
so if i can understand the question the
fear is
um you know
the expectations of your audience so
your current audience
if you've been established they're used
to longer form videos
and horizontal videos traditional videos
you start posting shorts they
go oh this is annoying and they might
unsubscribe could happen they might just
skip them
they might think they're fine by the way
you should always look you know because
you can see
this video is minus 13 subscribers this
video was my you know
like in your analytics you know i was
like and then you also see this video's
plus subscribers so you can see if
you're
net net gaining or losing subscribers on
any one upload
um i don't think you need to advertise
your long form content people could find
that out themselves
they can watch the one short be like
that was cool don't care about following
that person for any length of time
and move on or they go that was
interesting let me click through on
their channel or let me click subscribe
you could give a call to action to
subscribe and then that your videos
might start being recommended to them
so that's going to be a constant
evolution of the
tension to be managed of short versus
long form content on one
channel right you know a crazy example
of shorts that you need to know
is jake feldman and i think he's
kind of like one of the fastest growing
youtube channels maybe
maybe not ever but like pretty fast four
point almost five million subscribers
and he's posting all shorts seven
seconds 19 seconds
now he's doing like computer graphics
sometimes these shorts take him a really
long
time to make look at this five months
ago though 162
million views on this short
i believe talked to him on clubhouse um
you know i believe that this can take
him like two days because it's all
you know he's he's doing computer
rendering uh
computer rendering cg
computer graphics cgi okay
so you know crazy stuff he's got and and
he posts these on other platforms as
well
but that's absolutely bonkers levels of
reach you know tapping into
definitely probably a younger audience
the among us audience
um and it's all pure shorts brings up a
good point
you know people say because i believe
he's living in
alaska and and he still hasn't seen a
ton of money
or like enough to even like really
change his lifestyle
i think that's changed by now but a
couple months ago when i initially
was on clubhouse with him but
now he's in an entirely different place
and the opportunities coming to him are
crazy
i mean you get four you get five million
subs you start getting 162 million views
were shorts really the strategy of
shorts in my opinion
is maybe like think media it's probably
like we're testing it at like 10
15 of our strategy that's like how how
intense we are about it because we
are teachers we have education channels
so we this
this video about shorts is going on an
hour you know what i mean
and so uh but this is entertainment
this is reach into a certain demographic
so no question the way to really
monetize
brand deals think about how viners
monetized
viners got huge brand deals because they
built big audiences
in a specific demographic so really
brand partnerships brand sponsorships
remember influence comes first income
comes second
so if you could build influence um with
shorts
then income will follow later maybe not
in monetization via adsense but
definitely through brand deals
and um i hope that helps
and health with grace do we need to
upload a thumbnail on a short two
so back to the thumbnail tips you don't
need to upload a thumbnail
because we are concerned or aware of the
experience of our desktop
viewers you can see that this video
right here
is a short 44 seconds and it has
a thumbnail the thumbnail is for the
desktop viewers
this one um doing a little bit better is
got a thumbnail and it is for
desktop viewers and this one has got
some good traffic and is being
recommended
by youtube uh short shelf etc
on the short shelf on mobile it just is
really the first frame that's another
important thing to consider
the first frame although it starts so
quick but the first frame is
is it appears to be the thumbnail on the
short shelf
um and so up to you but to keep your
library clean and i think that's another
reason
here's to land the plane on this idea
this video
is valuable for desktop viewers
like if i can get five simple youtube
tips in less than a minute i can handle
that there's black bars on the side
personally i can i mean i know tony
aureoch on the team can't
but i can't because uh you know it's
like
thank god you didn't take a long time
you know telling me all this other stuff
like you got straight to the point
so we've seen if you will viewer
satisfaction how do you measure that
i mean likes dislikes is a good way like
27 dislikes
1 300 likes comments no one's seen
why is this a short i wish it was a
minute but horizontal like we didn't we
haven't seen that like people might
think that but
you should always be listening you know
and letting the math
life's dislikes inform you um
yeah okay do you recommend
memo in heart do you recommend creating
a new channel for shorts
or upload to your main channel i hit
that one earlier during the tips so
check out the replay for that one jesse
would it be a good idea to summarize the
message of a longer video you already
have on your channel i kind of hit that
as well
and i would say yes you know or to even
remake
here's a hint to remake a video that has
done well on your channel in shorts form
so one of the biggest questions we get
is how to remove glare in your
glasses and coming out um
in a few days is how to remove glare in
your glasses
short so nolan has a video it's crushing
of how to remove you know the light
glare in your glasses
and so omar is doing a shorts version um
again those can travel down two
different traffic paths on youtube
one the short shelf the soon coming you
know
shorts integration at the bottom of the
youtube app and anything else youtube
ads
whereas the other one might be being
recommended on smart tvs etc
so i think that's a great insight to
consider notice too
you know little like and share at the
end a little quick this was 31 seconds
total
and uh that full version we'll link to a
couple of our best shorts in the
description down below
so you can go directly to think media
ones to study a couple of those
um but uh always experimenting
jesse davis life hit like if you're
getting value and today's video
is brought to you by the youtube impact
challenge
um i cannot wait for this i am so fired
up that i
even wore the same fleece for coffee
with canal
that i had on in the picture yes since
then i've grown a beard
but uh that has nothing to do with the
youtube impact challenge
which is at ytimpack.com link in the
description down below
can you commit five days to really
getting serious about growing your
channel five days to build momentum five
days to clarify your audience
five days to clarify your monetization
strategies the best ways and
new ways to get views this year like the
latest tests we've been doing and
and all the experiments we do at think
media it's going to be power pack days
it's entirely free
yt the letters yt impact.com to register
for free
and um myself tony ariola melissa caputo
we're giving away a youtube studio
we're giving away a camera uh we're
giving away software we're giving away a
lot of cool stuff
uh tony's tip of the day if you've been
on a pass challenge is gonna be coming
hot every session heather taurus is
training on the think media team
um and uh we're just super fired up so
check out links in the description down
below to be a part of that all things
film will you have some more videos on
creating shorts and using youtube music
from the phone app
absolutely we have a series coming out
on think media
so insider
information what this is the think
marketing
youtube channel at the time of this very
live recording
we're pivoting the branding on this
channel to the think media
podcast it'll be the name of the channel
i think marketing is
no longer that the podcast has already
changed if you go to spotify and apple
um cue the violin music but we're
excited for just
it'll be the think media channel on the
think media podcast channel
if you have only met myself or heather
or any of the other team here on this
channel and you don't know we have a
channel called think media
head over there we got a whole short
series come out coming out
so if you've been a part of the fam
thanks for being a part of the fam
you want to make sure you subscribe to
think media and the soon coming
it'll be this exact channel where this
live is right now think media podcast
channel if you're already subscribed to
think
marketing you don't have to do anything
it'll just be a name change and a pivot
you heard it here first even though we
already rolled out the podcast yesterday
and nobody said anything because
apparently it doesn't it wasn't that big
of a change
um for these are my thoughts what should
we do
what should we make with shorts um
i'll leave this one for really cool
videos we're coming out we're gonna have
some videos on best ideas
what i here's here's my answer to the
question update your app
crash it and refresh it until you can
find your short shelf it does sometimes
take a while like i'm like i can't even
and then all of a sudden i'm like oh
there it is and it says shorts beta and
start watching shorts you've never got
as cool a homework as you're about to
get here's your homework
watch an hour of shorts like see what
youtube recommends to you
see as you like or dislike and go on to
the next one and engage with them
and watch with a journal out and write
down some ideas in the journal
success leaves clues
and then we will be bringing you some of
the best ideas
uh in that series budget worship leaders
would you recommend 45 second product
review that you're planning on doing a
full review later
in order to build interest for the full
video i would for two reasons
it maybe isn't even to build interest
it's just the two different versions
it's like um speaking of a budget
worship leader there's a church called
church home
and judah smith is the pastor and of
course they have
normal church on the weekend virtually
they stream in on their app and
everywhere
and then they started a new thing called
short church
because for people that are maybe on a
lunch break or just want to catch and he
just like summarizes the weekend message
the the interesting thing is is you may
not have caught the weekend message
so you're just serving people and
helping people at different levels
so yes people might want both they might
want to just watch the shorter version
they may never know that the other one
exists
they may engage on youtube pride
primarily on shorts meaning they they
consume shorts they love shorts they're
kind of a tick-tock-minded
viewer so they would never click on a
video that's
22 minutes or an hour and 36 minutes on
the flip side
you know people maybe might see a 45
second let's say they're watching on
desktop and they're like
45 seconds versus and i got a seven
minute option there's no way they could
cover all the details
you know what i mean so i think actually
one of the biggest mistakes
we make as creators
is we overestimate
how much even our dedicated viewers
watch of our content
let's say you got a thousand subscribers
you think all a thousand
watch every one of your videos you think
if
you talked about something at the first
of the month and then
six weeks later that's kind of the same
that
your audience is gonna be like what the
heck how did you post the same video
because what happens is maybe and this
rarely happens but maybe someone goes
did you post like something like this
before one person
but 99 of the people didn't see the
first one
or they forgot or they don't care i
don't know if
anybody's a garyvee fan like me dude you
watch garyvee for any length of time
you're gonna hear the exact same thing
i've been following him
for 10 years since i read crushin in
2009.
i'm not mad about it i'm like sometimes
i need to hear the same things so i want
i think the biggest mistake creators
make
is actually being a little bit of of
always trying to come up with
new content here's what i believe is
better
you actually should be saying the same
things in
new ways to new people rather than
always trying to say new things
so let's talk about the m50 for example
the m50 camera
in my opinion and we've done this it's
better to go deeper on the m50 than
trying to always
find some new camera or some new thing
and and and help people because it's
such an amazing camera and so many
people in our community have gotten it
help people in the community go deeper
on the camera talk about the camera more
compared to other cameras
the same thing someone might have been
like you already talked about the m50
well then don't
watch it if a repeat of the walking dead
or the simpsons
or the office plays you don't go well
any silence episode or maybe you do
turn it off there's other things to
watch on lifetime plus
like marrying millions there's other
things to watch
on discovery plus like undercover
billionaire season two with grant
cardone
turn it off if you've seen it before so
we're like so afraid
of like saying the same thing when
honestly the way you build a brand and
build momentum
is you say the same things in new ways
listen to new people
how do you reach new people you reach
them on youtube shorts
on tick tock on instagram i'm not gonna
say new things on tik tok
i might say in a new way because
it's the same thing but it's in the
short form format it's the same thing
but i got my peaches out in georgia and
i'm doing youtube's youtube tips as i
dance
it's the same thing that hasn't happened
yet we'll see it's you know what i mean
you contextualize your core message
the message that you're building on
youtube the flag you're planting the
brand you're planting the who you helped
the problem that you solve
but you're chopping it up and you're
making it unique
tik talk has a language youtube shorts
has a language so you're speaking
your core message in the native language
of
that modality of communication live
streaming has a language
smash like if you're getting value
during this live stream and shout me out
on a live chat and let me know where
you're watching from
you're not going to say that in a short
because it wouldn't even be accurate you
don't have enough time
so smash like if you're getting value
and if you wait if you want to
go deeper and here this is what i think
is the big challenge
sean what is my core message what is
the brand i'm i don't know who i'm
trying to reach i don't know the best
niche to be in i don't know how to
position myself
if that's some of the questions you have
definitely check out our challenge
um today's live stream is brought to you
by our challenge we'll be able to go
deeper on like how do you find
your who um how do you really define
what your channel is about how do you
clarify your
brand how do you clarify your messaging
i got a couple more questions to uh
answer but shout out we got the pacific
northwest in the house
we got the bay area in the house we got
ohio in the house
we got north carolina santa monica
come on uh and keep
smashing the like button
i know how to say button bhutan
baton pass the baton
button yeah phonetically type it out if
you know how to say button
in colorado no peach is out in colorado
uh someone was asking about modality
i mean modality different it might not
have been the right
word but but 15 seconds
two minutes 15 seconds in vertical
is is like uh maybe i mean content
format like a certain modality of
of expressing your message modality
the written word audio podcast
short form content tick talk we have a
video podcast people can listen to
the audio that's a modality
they can watch the video and listen to
the audio but if you're going to
condense the message into a youtube
short
it's going to be different so that's
kind of what i mean is
clarifying and defining what your core
message is and who you're helping and
then expressing that
in the different content formats and not
just repurposing this one
big people mistake people make too is
they sometimes it's fine if you
repurpose content
but like if you chop up a 20 minute long
audio podcast
and you try to fit it in like 60 seconds
and it doesn't really make sense you
just use a random part
it's how effective you are at expressing
your message in the allotted time
towards the mindset of the viewer on
instagram or the viewer on youtube
shorts
anyways uh just a couple thoughts
there and uh
and let's keep it going with some
questions
let me see if modality was even
the model product a particular mode in
which something
exists or is experienced or expressed so
i think that's right it's the mode in
which it's being
exists or it's experienced or expressed
how are people experiencing content
on shorts how do you express content on
shorts or tik tok
how does what form does it exist what's
the mode that it exists in
in short form versus vertical versus
horizontal
um i hope i didn't confuse if you
confuse you lose okay
for these are my thoughts
what do we do with shorts that's coming
budget worship leaders all right raise
the bar
how often should we post should we now
add it to our normal upload
a video a week plus a short or two
shorts by the way
some of the people who are going all in
on shorts are posting three to five
shorts a day
such and they're they're trying to crack
open the algorithm
really more in entertainment or kind of
pranks or humor
or dancing or different things and
they're just trying to go for those big
you know the more spaghetti you throw at
the wall you're just trying to see what
sticks
and trying to get a couple multi million
viewed videos that leads to you know
hopefully hundreds of thousands and
millions of subscribers
hopefully to blow up a brand and
awareness and then maybe do brand deals
or whatever
you got to know the game you're playing
you got to know the angle you're going
for
and you got to know how many hours you
have in a day to create content
that in my opinion would be a terrible
idea
to do on think media when people expect
five normal videos
and all of a sudden we start hitting
with like three shorts a day so it's
kind of up to you raise the bar
my recommendation there would be by the
way
before here's a recommendation for
everybody before committing to something
like before you go i need to start doing
one short a week no you don't you just
need to do one short
like the really next step is not to make
a lifelong commitment you have to marry
shorts
till death do you part you just just try
one
and then try another one and and then
maybe develop your strategy from there
so even before
you decide what your content strategy is
or your content schedule is
that's that's again the cart before the
horse do a testing phase
shorts is in beta do a beta phase where
you post
a short this week you post a short today
or get it ready today post it tomorrow
post one post a couple over the next
month see how it went
read the comments depending on if you're
getting comments already and you're
getting feedback
and then maybe develop your strategy
listen i've expressed in this video what
i believe our strategy is going to be
but we are constantly strategizing but
also willing to pivot
our plan based on
our gut based on data based on audience
feedback
and we are you know creating alchemy
out of all of that feedback to determine
what our future strategy is and i'll
always be here
as long along with the think media team
to help you as well
and so um let me know did you get value
today
out of this video smash like and did you
um have you posted a short question of
the day yet are you going to post your
first
short let me know and uh
you ytimpak.com it's happening my
friends
may 18th yt impact.com
live it's happening on facebook if you
hate facebook if you don't want to be on
facebook
if you then you can't be a part of the
challenge like
i'm sorry that's where it's happening
why don't you do it somewhere else
we'll maybe do it somewhere else in the
future but um
right now it's on facebook so it's in a
private facebook group the entry point
to get into everything is
ytnpack.com link in the description down
below for five days
we're gonna be breaking down how do you
really create a youtube channel that
grows
how do you really break through the
noise how do you really clarify your
brand
clarify your mission your message find
your people
find your who and then develop content
that
not just earns an income so you can make
a living
from youtube but you can also make a
difference you know our mission at think
media
is to help ten thousand purpose-driven
people create a full-time living doing
what they love while making a difference
in the world with
youtube and so this
is at the heart of that we've done a
couple challenges in the past we've
never done a five-day challenge the
five-day youtube impact challenge
so there's some new and exciting things
happening we're giving away a camera
uh we're giving away a youtube studio
and it's going to be amazing so if you
want to be a part of that
um the goal is to be there live that's
where the action's happening
but we do leave the replays up for so
you can look at the schedule
for a very limited time and so no matter
what it's a good idea to register
if you want to get that exclusive
content that just goes a lot deeper than
anything that we
even have the time or depth to share
here on youtube and so ytimpact.com
is uh where the youtube impact five day
challenge is happening
starting may 18th it's gonna be fun it's
gonna be live
myself and the entire think media team
are going
to be there uh the challenge is
the first hour is tony's quick tip q a
giveaways and training
the second hour is the vip q a um but
the first hour is the core content
and two days we're gonna have um an
extra afternoon session but it's mostly
in the morning um for five days tuesday
through saturday
um and it's gonna be a lot of fun i just
got the shorts camera
yeah awesome update your youtube app if
you haven't got
that yet and so uh check that out
victoria
vra fam in the house vra's been a
blessing i'm super grateful you're
loving it
um and if you're just joining um then
uh check out the replay because we
covered a lot of in-depth content about
shorts
21 tips uh and so the video will reflect
and you
refresh and you can watch the video
right here on youtube um thanks so much
for being here coffee with kennel until
next time my name is sean cannell
and remember punch fear in the face
punch perfectionism
in the face and just press record
peace